cries of desperation from migrants in
weeksla mexico
they're calling on authorities to grant
them humanitarian transit visas
after waiting for days this family from
venezuela have finally had their
paperwork approved
the documents allow them to move freely
through mexico and make their way toward
the u.s southern border
after almost three weeks this represents
one less obstacle at least now we have a
permit to transit the country now we
need to figure out how to get the money
for bus tickets and try to look for work
most of these people arrived here as
part of a migrant caravan that left the
city of tapachula near mexico's border
with guatemala on monday
the mass of people marching on the road
seemed endless
frustrated with the slow pace some moved
on ahead
other people chose to wait for their
transit visas
and in just a few days what was once a
caravan of thousands mostly cease to
exist
maria and oscar also from venezuela have
decided to make their way toward mexico
city by bus along with their young
daughter and about a dozen other
migrants
they're exhausted but optimistic that
their hardships will soon be over
the truth is this has been very
difficult we crossed the jungle there
were many people who died others who
couldn't go any further i don't wish
what we've been through on anyone we've
experienced hunger and thirst
but we have many hopes and dreams of
arriving at our destination
it's a long road toward the mexican
capital once there they'll only be a few
days away from arriving on the doorstep
of the united states
with their transit visas in hand many
migrants will continue north aboard
buses like the one we're on now those
traveling without the necessary
paperwork run the risk of being detained
and sent back to southern mexico to
start their journey again manuel rapalo
al jazeera chiapas mexico